John Stewart was just asked from
Apple and and he had this new show it's
called the problem with John Stewart his
first big show since he left the daily
show and the show gets canceled pretty
early why did Apple TV cancel John
Stewart there are two competing
narratives one says they canceled him
because he had low ratings the other
narrative clearly being leaked by his
team is that they canceled him because
he wanted to criticize China and he
wanted to criticize artificial intellig
and Apple is very warm with China and
with artificial intelligence so they had
an ideological disagreement they shut
him up which is it well we got the
numbers some estimates put JN Stewart's
viewership on this Apple TV show as low
as 40,000 us
homes that is
nothing that that is barely a blip
forget about compared to a network TV
audience or even a cable TV audience
compared to a small podcast those are
bad
numbers so okay he had the low ratings
but then the reports say that he was
planning shows on China on Israel
actually too and on AI and apple because
it does a lot of business with China
Apple which would collapse if we if we
decoupled with China and uh artificial
intelligence obviously is important to
Apple uh they don't like those topic so
they kill it which is it which destroyed
JN Stewart's
show the answer is both it's obviously
both John Stewart has always had low
ratings he was a cultural phenomenon
when he had the Daily Show on Comedy
Central that show didn't get a lot of
viewers it was relatively low rated but
the people who watched it tended to be
journalists and the chattering political
class concentrated in the coasts very
liberal who had an outsized microphone
so they made a big deal out of his show
Even though relatively few people
watched it in the
country the low ratings can be
forgiven as long as you are dancing to
the tune that the liberal Elite are
playing that's the issue when when John
Stewart was dancing as the Court Jester
of the liberal regime which is what his
job was at The Daily Show they loved him
and they made a big deal out of him and
they made him famous and they made him
wealthy even though not a lot of people
watched his show but now that he's maybe
turning against some of what the the in
class want especially in China and AI
well now those low ratings are not going
to be forgiven and they're going to take
away his Fame and they're going to take
away his money and he's going to see how
illusory all of those things actually
were and he's going to learn a lesson
that a lot of us have forgotten which is
true in politics and it's true in
business and it's true in all of public
life he who pays the piper calls the
tune right now go to genucell.com our
friends over at genell have launched a
new product called genu cell 3 which
works fast on your under eye bags and
puffiness genu cell 3 is smooth and
luxurious and it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration it's like Gatorade for
your skin this new genus cell technology
keeps your skin looking young and
healthy for years to come the genus cell
fall Classics package also includes a
jawline treatment for a more firm neck
and jawline as well as genus cell's
anti- wrinkle moisturizer and deep
Firming Serum right now go to
genucell.com
wle for extra discounts on this amazing
fall package get your skin ready for the
cold and dry weather if you don't look
and feel your absolute best you will get
your money back no questions guaranteed
that is genucell.com you know I love
this company I love the founder is Copic
Christian from Egypt who fled over here
for the American dream go to genucel.com
klees now speaking of dancing to other
people's tune I've got a very disturbing
story that just came out and it's
disturbing in that it's super creepy and
spooky and kind of zombie like and it's
just in time for Halloween but it's it's
actually a satisfying story because it
vindicates a lot of old wisdom and the
story is
this blood transfusions might change
your
personality if you get a lot of people
get blood
transfusions there is scientific
evidence that you don't just get blood
and you don't just get platelets you get
an increased risk of
certain diseases okay maybe you could
say well it's just a protein or
something was going along with the blood
and you get
potentially changes in your personality
and your mood and your tastes and it's
really really weird researchers at the
Kolinski Institute in Sweden published a
major study that showed that a cause of
spontanous anous brain hemorrhage could
be transmitted via blood transfusion as
I said that could just be some protein
or something like
that but it might go deeper than that
and there's a lot of evidence that it
does go deeper 5 years ago a study by
Geneva University reported that nearly
half of patients reported changes in
their behavior and values after
receiving blood transfusions there have
also been well popular well publicized
stories rather of people who had organ
transplants and then their taste changed
in the US there was a 47-year-old woman
who had a lung transplant from an
18-year-old and then immediately had a
craving for beer and fried chicken which
were things that this woman had not
previously craved but that every
18-year-old in the country does crave
the researchers interviewed seven people
who' received blood
transfusions uh for things like hip
replacements and other surgeries they
found out three of the seven believed
that their personalities had changed one
said he slept and dreamt a lot more than
before another said his sense of taste
had changed and he found this worrying
he said I hope that the donor's blood
cannot take
over this is really great news even
though it's spooky and creepy because
this is a Vindication of classical
anthropology this is a Vindication of
the old way of of viewing human
nature not the new way of viewing human
the new way of viewing human nature is
that we're all just Machines man we're
like computers plug and playay you know
and we're just we're we're like a hard
drive and and different like just like
in different parts of a machine you can
just pull out our parts and they're
interchangeable and you can plug them
into new people it's no big deal the
classical understanding of human nature
is is not that the classical
understanding of human nature is that we
are an integrated whole that we are a
primary substance that you can't just
plug and play our different parts like
on a car you know on a car you can go in
you take out a catalytic converter from
one car you can put it into another car
and it's going to work just fine you can
pull out the transmission here you can
plug it in because to use the old
terminology a car and all these other
created things they're just artifacts we
make them so they're not they're not
totally
integrated in the way that a human being
is a human being being primary substance
made by
God one problem for this old view of
human nature in recent years has been
that it seems like with transplants we
actually are kind of like the catalytic
converter we actually are like a car or
like any other artifact you just plug us
and play us and there's so many people
especially prominent voices in the
academy and in the government and in the
cultural Elite who say yeah we're just
machines we think we have free will we
think we have souls we think we have
desires and longings and meaning but
it's all just fake it's an illusion made
by firing pistons in our brain even the
term Pistons you know to compare it to a
car and uh so you're just deluding
yourself you're just
but maybe not maybe our our organs don't
just plug and play like that maybe
actually it's all part of that one
person and you could get a blood
transfusion and things start to go a
little haywire and you start you start
craving chicken and beer and you start
maybe they're they're really for us and
we are one thing that is integrated not
just in our body but take it it one step
further maybe we're integrated Body and
Soul maybe maybe we're actually not
machines
but human beings who
knew every wise person for all of
history is the answer until very
recently and then we said those guys are
dumb idiots and we're modern and we have
cell phones so we know that that they're
all wrong and we're right about
everything well maybe not maybe we
actually are human beings boy what a
weird clip that was now hey hey hey hey
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
N show see you next time